fait passer pour un client d'un contact
je reçois ces messages de proposition de
prêt
franchement c'est dur les premiers
messages encore maintenant je me revois
vraiment fondre et c'est dur c'est
tellement bien carrément des ajustements
des mamans conjoint d'ouvrir les
messages dans ma place parce que je
pouvais voir ou si je tombe sur des
champions j'ai encore des images
prochain en sectionnant la fille j'en
profite donc ouais c c'était dur elle a
rencontré un garçon
donc tu es les termes voisins par amour
tu peux foudres de l'adolescence et
celui qui est devenu son proxénète avec
le temps
tu avec l âge
treize cantons font quand a commencé à
fuguer qu'il fallait commencer à brûler
dans les hôtels j'étais à manger tout
pourrait rentrer en revenus
pour être ses parfums bruel déjà c'était
banalisée donc je pense pas qu'elle a
institué celui là mais ça a dû me
chômage puisqu'à la prostitution et
c'était être être devenus le robinet
du coup bah il m'a fallu la retracer sur
les sites cherchent les lieux où elles
disent exercer
les endroits au boulot j'ai
scruté ces photos chercher son corps sur
des sites
[Musique]
où le travail d'investigation
ça vaut bien tous travaillent
bien c'est ce que j'ai fait pendant deux
ans mais les phocéens petit set d'anti
sais pas vous étés par la police avant
d'avouer yousaf
au départ bajeux des prouesses plane sur
tous puisque je suis à toulouse elle
après selon le lieu où elle se trouve et
je me déplace je vais dans les
commissaires incompétent je vais même
dans des lieux où je sais qu'elle a été
hébergé pendant sa fugue je trouve des
vêtements à elle
j'appelle les forces de la en train
franchement je vais blues mais rien à
faire là toujours les mêmes phrases
territorialement incompétent
une reddition judiciaire trop long
temps j'avais été portée pour
elle avait des bleus quand je vais te
ramener cette fois l'attaqué des bleus
on avait fait un constat avec des
hématomes c'était vraiment une
serpillière elle est dans un sale état
l'avenger éviter de creuser tuberculose
latente asia être été un déclic et tu
t'es dit cette relation à l'eva pour moi
en fait le fait que vous savez mais
j'ai pas je ne voyais pas avec quelqu'un
d'autre que j'avais que lui
la thématique basiques d'une fille quand
on s'offre un garçon pour la première
fois qu'on enlève est tabou qu'on a sur
notre corps on est en confiance c'est
vrai que dans chaque histoire quand elle
se termine je te vois difficilement être
aussi à l'aise avec quelqu'un d'autre
derrière ce côté là et en plus de ça il
y avait vraiment l'emprise dans le sens
où il était isolé et avait que lui ont
fait les frais et sans oublier qu'ils se
parlaient pas
à les regarder netflix puisque elle
parlait plus à personne c'était
tellement important car créer un cercle
social et j'ai contacté plein
d'associations en plein de chose qui
pourrait me permettre puisqu'elle
n'était pas scolarisé va lui permettre
de recréer salle paix sociale ben y'a
pas à lui offrant un chien errant
promener le chien qu'elle a rencontré du
monde d'ailleurs c'est devenu son
meilleur ami en juin dernier vous avez
créé une association à nous elle doit
oublier pour aider les parents démunis
face à ce phénomène sur quoi vous
souhaiteriez agir
laurent premiers à pouvoir être un lieu
d'accueil d'accueil pour ses parents
pour sélective autant pouvoir les
informer les conseiller ou les guider
autant si c'est des jeunes victimes pour
avoir le droit de recueillir leurs
informations qu'elles seront recevables
pouvoir rencontrer sur place autant les
victimes ou les fugueuses aux fugueurs
ou encore en ce moment ils sont dans
leurs locaux quand
je passe il ya moyen d'avoir un
partenariat par exemple un peu dégueu
quant à une famille qui a une audience
que juge des enfants voilà constate que
la prostitution mais ce ne serait ce
qu'au pouvoir être
conseillées auprès de cette famille ou
de ce gène suis pas policière j'ai pas
éducatrice peut-être que de parler de
quelque chose qu'on a vécu ou même
patient entre guillemets puisque elle
s'investit en tant que secrétaire de
l'association peut-être que de pouvoir
avoir une approche différente avec ces
jeunes ça pourrait être bénéfique ça
pourrait
leur donner
une peu de confiance ou un peu de force
pour parler moi c'est tous déjà pas à
100% mais
résultat tous ces jeunes qui ont vécu
une souffrance un traumatisme vie qui a
été victime de quelque chose mais qui
n'ont jamais été reconnus en occupent la
majorité c'est ça
assia bas ça a été le début c'est son
grand-père ou à la femme étaient
reconnus mais craignait elle a pu être
entendu et est depuis la création de
l'association avait rencontré pas mal de
parents de victimes
notamment une sur toulouse qui avait été
violée dans un collège finalement cette
prostituée l'autre qui avait été
frappé par certains de la famille
paternelle classée sans suite par ci sur
la prostitution parce que vous avez
lorsque vous attaquez à une montagne
parce qu'on va dire c'est un cas des
montagnes en fait dont tu as quelque
chose
pour sauver ainsi un style montagne je
vois que dans la vie c'est comme de tout
un petit ce sens